des tests pcr salivaires dans les
établissements scolaires dès la rentrée
la mesure a été annoncée depuis
plusieurs semaines dans les faits aucune
information n'a pour le moment été
donnée aux parents ni aux enseignants
les syndicats se disent inquiets à
quelques jours de la mise en place de
ces tests moins invasif que les
écouvillon sébastien branget les tests
naso pharyngé plutôt désagréable c'est
fini
du moins dans les maternelles et les
écoles primaires il devrait être
remplacé par les tests salivaires dès ce
lundi dans les établissements scolaires
du premier degré en tout cas c'est ce
que le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer a annoncé faut que
les administrations trouvent les
personnels en sachant que les cellules
des affaires scolaires sont très peu
nombreux départements et quels sont déjà
débordés par sont des charges qu'elle
soit à faire donc il va falloir qu'ils
trouvent ou qu'ils aient quand pour le
faire et c'est là dessus je pense qu'on
pense qu'il va y avoir un problème comme
pour les tests antigénique qui
finalement dans les écoles collèges et
lycées
à quelques jours du début de la campagne
de dépistage en indre et loire
personne n'est vraiment au courant des
modalités côté académique c'est silence
radio
malgré nos relances les enseignants eux
ne sont toujours pas informés et pour
les parents d'élèves en bout de chaîne
c'est le flou lauriane et mère de deux
enfants et professeurs bien que d'accord
sur le principe de ce test salivaire
elle s'interroge sur l'organisation de
cette campagne
ça me parait manon compliqué à mettre en
place lundi dans la mesure où l'école ne
m'a pas prévenu nous sommes en vacances
je vois comment elle pourrait me
prévenir j'ai signé aucune autorisation
j'ai deux enfants dans deux écoles
différentes donc je ne peux pas couper
ma carte vitale ont 2,6 faut que leur
laisse la carte vitale
la rs centre val de loire précise
néanmoins que la campagne de dépistage
ne débuteraient réellement qu'en milieu
ou fin de semaine prochaine